j'ai eu plusieurs vies comme beaucoup
d'entre nous d'ailleurs
j'ai souvent eu l'impression que je
rentre un peu que je rentrais pas dans
les cases
j'ai été sept enfants parisienne
scolarisés dans une classe de toutes les
couleurs et puis j'ai été parachuté dans
un petit village de campagne où j'ai
grandi
un village de 300 habitants où les gens
n'avaient jamais vu de ville a encore
moins de parisiens alors ça a sûrement
été mon premier choc culturel mais en
même temps je n'ai pas vécu comme ça
parce que c'est vrai que quand on est
enfant on n'a pas cette notion de la
différence
je suis de deux origines différentes de
la méditerranée d'un pays de l'est et ma
famille a marqué par une histoire de
migration qui dont on m'a jamais
vraiment tout dit au hasard de mon
parcours personnel et professionnel
je me suis retrouvé au pakistan et j'ai
passé du temps et j'apprenais la langue
et je crois que quand on apprend une
langue c'est un peu de la culture qu'on
intègre aussi et ça nous permet d'avoir
un oeil neuf sur notre propre culture
je suis musulmane dans une famille non
musulmanes je suis française et ça c'est
une partie de mon identité dont j'ai
pris conscience et dont j'ai appris à
être fière en voyageant je suis
travailleuse sociale et en tant que
travailleuse sociale j'ai dû composer
avec les conflits ethniques
j'ai dû faire le lien entre les gens
entre les cultures
je suis entrepreneur est depuis des
années je vis dans un pays d'un an dans
un département que je porte dans mon
coeur parce qu'il ressemble à aucun
autre c'est le 93 alors tous à ces
départs de mon identité c'est des
morceaux de vie qui me kim composés qui
font ce que je suis ils font aussi que
j'ai souvent eu l'impression que j'avais
du mal à m'adapter que je devais rentrer
dans des cases
ils font que j'ai connu très tôt les
clivages entre les gens et ils ont fait
quelques mois de moi quelqu'un de très
intuitif qui sent littéralement des
legends alors j'ai souvent eu du mal à y
mettre du sens et c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué d'expliquer tout ça à
quelqu'un en une seule phrase alors
commencer l'expliqué à soi même quand tu
es à paris on me demande pour te
connaître
qu'est ce que tu fais comme si grave si
ton activité professionnelle pouvait
suffire à définir et quand on est dans
les quartiers on me demande c'est quoi
pour connaître son origine ethnique
alors ça aussi c'est un petit peu
réducteur qui suis-je
ça c'est la grande question à laquelle
souvent une vie ne suffit pas pour
répondre
toute ma vie j'ai fait des choses
instinctivement des choses qui me
plaisait sans forcément penser à long
terme sans penser à une carrière ou
comment j'allais gagner ma vie ça
c'était sûrement pour répondre à cette
question justement et pour me trouver
alors j'ai fait la sociologie
j'ai appris des langues l'arabe lourdes
ou le pachto j'ai étudié le travail
social la religion la couture je me suis
formé à la médiation interculturelle à
la création d'entreprise et j'avais pas
bien où tout ça allait mener alors mon
premier vrai travail c'est un france
terre d'asile
france terre d'asile c'est une
association qui accompagne les migrants
et les demandeurs d'asile et moi je
m'occupais des mineurs donc on allait la
nuit dans les camps de migrants essayer
de les identifier
pour les mettre à l'abri et ensuite je
me battais pour leur prise en charge par
les services sociaux
souvent ce qui était le plus difficile à
gérer je pense j'ai été aussi dans leurs
yeux la grande soeur celle qui parlaient
la même langue
ensuite j'ai travaillé à la croix rouge
encore comme comme travailleuse sociale
auprès des migrants et comme interprète
et puis au bout d'un moment je me suis
senti un petit peu limité dans mes
actions et puis j'avais l'impression que
j'étais un peu impuissante
c'est vrai qu'on était très limité dans
les moyens qu'on avait et par le cadre
légal
et puis surtout j'ai compris quelque
chose c'est que malgré mes cinq licences
et mon master je montrais jamais les
échelons parce que je rentrais pas dans
les bonnes cases
j'étais pas dans la norme là non alors
on vit dans une société de la norme et
et cette norme j'en ai vite pris
conscience parce que j'en faisais pas
partie en était exclue et cette
exclusion j'ai vécu comme très violente
et très injuste alors ça a donné chez
moi des comportements un peu bizarre
comme le fait de devoir tout le temps de
justifier le fait de devoir toujours
m'expliquer le fait de m'écraser dans
les mêmes jusqu'à m'effacer j'avais
l'impression de devoir toujours en faire
des tonnes pour paraître crédible alors
j'étais une personne la journée une
autre le soir
mais en fait je suis sûr vous voyez tous
de quoi je parle parce que finalement on
passe notre temps à naviguer d'un monde
à l'autre à mettre en avant l'une au lot
de nos facettes pour paraître le mieux
possible en fonction de l'interlocuteur
qu'on a en face de nous et finalement
c'est tellement usant de jamais de soi
même jusqu'à aujourd'hui il m'arrive de
sentir à quel point ça être normal elle
m'étrangle elle m'étouffe j'ai
l'impression c'est que c'est comme un
ennemi à combattre un ennemi invisible
contre lequel je donne débattre pour
faire ma place et j'ai compris autre
chose aussi
j'ai compris à quel point elle peut
mener à des dérives c'est qu'elle exclue
et ce qu'elle écrase de son indifférence
je vais essayer de vous expliquer un
petit peu ce sentiment ces sentiments
c'est quand la société tout entière tu
fais comprendre que tu es invisible
quand on me fait comprendre que t'es pas
à ta place et que finalement quoi que tu
fasses tu y seras jamais parce que c'est
toi dans ton être même qui n'est pas
normal je crois que l'identité un lien
profond avec la dignité
alors quand on essaye de recruter
quelqu'un de son identité ou d'une
partie de son identité finalement c'est
un morceau de sa dignité qu'on enlève
est le sentiment qui reste c'est de
l'humiliation alors l'humiliation c'est
souvent le sentiment le pire pour l'être
humain est ce que qu'est-ce qui nous
tient debout à part notre dignité
l'humiliation ça donne envie de tout
exploser ça donne envie de tout brûler
ça donne envie de le détester la terre
entière
ça donne envie de de venger ça donne
envie de pleurer
ça donne envie de rester chez toi
enfermé ça donne envie de d'éviter
certains endroits pour pas avoir à la
subir ça donne envie de de faire
certains choix pour pas avoir à y faire
face
moi aussi j'aimerais choix à faire
c'était soit je me laissais effacés je
me replier sur moi même ou sur des gens
qui était censé me ressembler soit je
revivais la tête
je m'assume et avec toutes mes identités
j'ai accepté ce que je représentais
malgré moi dans les yeux des gens et je
veux montrer mon potentiel je faisais
entendre ma voix
alors ça c'était pas la solution la plus
facile parce que c'est toujours un peu
compliqué de sortir de sa zone de
confort mais on m'avait appris que rien
n'était impossible
et moi je croyais en des valeurs les
valeurs que que mon père qui est un
exemple de dignité et de l'intégrité
m'avait apprise des valeurs que j'avais
vu chez ma mère aussi féministe elle qui
a toujours fait le travail d'un homme à
la maison des valeurs d'égalité de
liberté des valeurs qu'en fait j'avais
apprises pendant toutes ces vies et je
voulais m'en servir finalement tout ça
je l' ai compris
j'ai compris que ces identités c'était
une force grâce à l'entrepreneuriat je
crois et je vais vous raconter une
petite histoire que qu'un afghan m'a
raconté à quelques semaines
c'est l'histoire d'un vieil homme qui
est penché sur la terre dure et qui est
en train de creuser qui essayent de
planter un figuier et à des jeunes
qu'ils regardent et qui qui rigole un
peu qui se moque de vie et qui finissent
par interpeller et lui disent eh bah bah
pourquoi tu te fatigues à creuser pour
planter un arbre dont tu mangerait
jamais les fruits et les regarder leur
dis mes fils si mon grand-père avant moi
n'avaient pas planté d'arbres j'aurais
pas manger de fruits pendant toute ma
vie alors cette histoire je voulais vous
la raconter parce que je les ai beaucoup
aimé déjà parce que planter un arbre
s'est donné la vie et aussi parce que ça
montre à quel point on a une
responsabilité collective sur les
générations futures mais aussi sur le
monde qui nous entoure aujourd'hui je
crois qu'à ce moment là mon parcours
j'ai eu besoin de me demander moi aussi
quelle fille gaie je pourrais bien
implanté et quels fruits ge pourrait
répandre autour de moi je me suis
demandé ce qui serait le plus juste avec
moi
qu'est-ce qui me rendrait justice qu'est
ce qu'il serait plus le plus logique
qu'avec mon parcours avec toutes ces
identités qui me composé et et
finalement il ya plein de formes
d'engagement mais celle qui sera la plus
vrai à la plus sincère c'est celle qui
sera le prolongement logique de toutes
ces identités
mon père m'a dit un jour
toi tu aura peut-être pas d'argent mais
tu serais riche et cette fraise à
marquer alors quand j'ai créé golson en
2014 marque de prêt-à-porter je les fais
un peu instinctivement comme tout ce que
j'avais fait jusque là j'avais été cette
femme pakistanaise
j'avais pensé à mon honneur j'avais
dépendu des âmes et ça même les plus
grandes convictions féministes pouvait
rien y faire dans un pays où la mixité
n'existe pas
au pakistan les femmes travaillent très
peu et un général elles sont très peu
éduqués parce qu'elles sont pas destinés
à travailler et à linverse ne sont pas
embauchés parce qu'elles sont pas formés
donc il ya un espèce dans l'engrenage
qui se met en place et qui fait que
quand elles ont vraiment besoin d'eux
quand elles ont vraiment besoin de
travailler pour survivre comme dans le
cas de divorce avec tous les problèmes
d'honneur que ça entraîne ou dans le cas
du décès de leur mari elles n'ont pas
d'autre choix que de se tourner vers la
mendicité ou de se retrouver victimes de
trafic donc j'ai créé j'ai monté un
atelier de confection textile pour
l'insertion des femmes veuves les
divorcées au pakistan et dans le
prolongement de ce projet social on a
créé la marque gucci annonce repensé qui
est commercialisé en france et en europe
alors ça j'ai pas fait pour je n'ai pas
fait pour me donner bonne conscience par
paternalisme je les fais parce que
finalement cette femme ça aurait pu être
moi c'était quelque chose qui était
logique par rapport à mon histoire et
qui avait du sens pour moi je suis pas
quelqu'un qui est qui aiment la mode
j'ai jamais vraiment aimé la mode j'ai
jamais feuilleter les magazines de mode
mais là c'est à ce moment là c'est ce
qui m'a semblé être le bon vecteur pour
faire passer le message que j'avais à
faire passer c'est ce qui m'a semblé
être le bon moyen de pour avoir une
vraie action sociale alors je me suis
aussi rendu compte qu'on était peut-être
à une génération de perdre des
savoir-faire que qui sont précieux si on
les préserver pas c'est aussi un moyen
de les préserver et de devrait pour une
consommation et une production plus
responsable et je voulais aussi faire un
petit pied de nez à la norme et pouvoirs
créé d'événements qui me ressemblait
sansan qui me soient imposées
aujourd'hui on n'a pas
- le choix en fait on peut pas faire
comme si nos comportements n'impact ait
pas autour de nous que ce soit de
manière négative ou positive aujourd'hui
même un clic sur internet peut avoir
avoir une répercussion à l'autre bout du
monde et donc je crois que le frein à
tout ça finalement c'est de revenir à ce
qui fait sens pour nous pour chacun
d'entre vous et de se demander ce qui
fera sens à l'intérieur de vous pour
faire sens autour de vous je suis
persuadé que si vous trouvez quelque
chose qui a du sens pour vous ça
impactera de manière positive autour de
vous aujourd'hui je sais qui je suis et
je fais ce que je suis je suis à ma
place partout j'estime être à ma place
et j'ai compris que toutes ces identités
c'était c'était ma force et ma richesse
et j'ose croire que c'est aussi une
force et une richesse pour la société
finalement on est tous des déracinés
personne n'est plus légitime à un
endroit que quelqu'un d'autre
et justement parce qu'on m'attend pas
quelque part j'ai envie d'y être
alors ce que je fais aujourd'hui c'est
pas de la mode c'est pas du business
c'est une manière de changer les choses
c'est une manière de donner du sens
j'essaye de faire de l'âme d'un outil
pour changer les représentations pour
casser la norme pour mettre en avant des
visages qu'on voit jamais des femmes qui
sont invisibles et parce que je crois à
ma conception de l'égalité
j'agis aussi auprès des jeunes des
quartiers pour les accompagner dans
l'orientation et qu'ils soient pas mal
orienté je m'implique aussi dans
l'entreprenariat féminin par une
association qui s'appelle acabit par
lequel des femmes sont accompagnées des
femmes de la diversité et des quartiers
sont elles sont accompagnées vers
l'entrepreneuriat et je suis également
formatrice dans une association qui
s'appelle singa et et je forme les
réfugiés à la création d'entreprise tous
ces combats en fait je les mène pour que
pour qu on vivre dans une société plus
juste où chacun ait sa place et où oui
aucun bagage origines aspects
zik quartier ou quoi que ce soit qui
puisse nous handicaper on a tous notre
place et j'ai envie qu'on se nourrissent
de cette pluralité
depuis quelques mois je me suis je me
suis lancé dans un nouveau projet
c'est c'est peut-être finalement
l'aboutissement de de tout ce parcours
j'ai créé afin de project une
association par laquelle on promet la
sorcière des femmes en situation de
migration par le savoir-faire textile
parce que j'ai envie que tous les tous
les potentiels soient valorisés ça fait
partie de mon combat est en fait j'ai
juste envie de changer le monde
alors j'ai une dernière petite demande
pour vous ce soir vous vous rappelez
cette histoire du vieil homme afghans
qui y est qui voulait planter son
figuier
je voudrais que ce soir vous rentrez
chez vous et vous vous demandiez vous
aussi que quelques figues et vous allez
pouvoir planter deux mains merci
[Applaudissements]